che cosa stai facendo qualcosa di harry
potter
[Musica]
ma ancora tu che cosa vuoi solo di
questo ok che cosa voi sala rischiosi
quindi vuol dire che vi ruberà itu tutti
i regali e allora che cosa devo fare
avete sentito devo trovare tutti i
regali di natale altrimenti le ruberà
l'impostore non mi raccomando lasciate
un bel mi piace se questo video
raggiunge i 15 mila mi piace ci sarà un
altro episodio in cui devo trovare i
regali di natale alla fine del video
scrivetemi pure nei commenti qual è il
regalo che vi è piaciuto più di tutti
perché andremo anche ad aprirli oggi ma
ora sbrighiamoci c'è pochissimo tempo
guardate questo è il regalo che mi ha
attirato in testa che cos'è unboxing del
primo regalo vediamo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
degli evidenziatori brillantinati
proviamoli subito eccoli qua
che voto date a questo regalo
vediamo se c'è qualcosa qua in salotto
mi raccomando se vedete qualcosa anche
voi scrivete melo e avvisatemi qua non
c'è niente tutto vuoto degli stati
chiedendo se quelli sono i regali
nascosti da l'impostore il nono sono
quelli quelli sono i regali da parte mia
per vitale e da parte di vitale per
mettiti con gli esiti sapere che cosa al
toro la sua su mi piace se volete che
facciamo la borsa eccolo un regalo la
scusa ha detto sì all trovato un altro
regalo
direi che per ora la salvezza sta
andando benissimo già trovato tre regali
o no mi sembrava troppo strano che fosse
così facile ha sabotato il reattore
dobbiamo per forza tornare al piano di
sopra e fermare il sabotaggio e poi
continuare la ricerca e aprire questi
regali
andiamo
controllare che come free bosello tempo
[Musica]
caduta un regalo
ho salvato il reattore e in più
l'impostore mentre scattava è caduto un
regalo quindi un altro prossimo boxing
da quale iniziamo iniziamo da questo
qualcosa di harry potter harry potter
mystery cube e tipo una mistery box di
harry potter
vediamo cosa si può capitare ci sono
vari personaggi e ci può capitare o dop
i tg i folletti drago la fenice di
polipo grata stinchi tra questi quello
che mi interessa di più è la fenice e
edvige vediamo chi troviamo guardate che
colore pure cuba lei e non la scarto da
wow
si dice che ben era anche il suo stand
ma è una miniatura servizio sui libri e
qua c'è lo sfondo questa è la sala
comune di grifondoro che bello wow
bellissimo questa mister i bokke voto
date a questo regalo prossimo boxing si
chiama c'è qualcos'altro di harry potter
[Applauso]
sono le capsule magiche di harry potter
dieci personaggi da collezionare
vediamo subito come ma ci sono i numeri
per andare in ordine aprendo le
caselline vediamo se riuscite indovinare
il personaggio dagli indizi qua c'è lo
stemma di coquin impronta digitale forse
devo premere giugno idea di chi possa
essere poi secondo indizio
questo è un bigliettino una goccia
d'acqua quindi forse lo deve immergere
nell'acqua vediamo che preso un
bicchiere d'acqua per la bella e la
bestia vediamo apparsa una scritta
guardate c'è scritto reduci un
incantesimo ma nessuno che incantesimo
sia in effetti non lo conosco questo
incantesimo reduce non ho idea di chi
possa essere il personaggio il secondo
voi chi è che ti amo qual è l'altra
casellina che devo aprire tre
eccola qua ci sono delle bustine ok 4
breve esserci una creatura magica da qua
penso che capiremo chi è quindi apriamo
magari prima qua dovrebbe essersi la
bacchetta vediamo da questo forse
riusciremo a capire il personaggio è con
la bacchetta riconoscete qualcuno da
questa bacchetta e piccolissima forse
potrebbe essere mal fuori o piton
apriamo il prossimo indizio c'è una
pozione d'amore che potrebbe essere
prossimo indizio abbiamo qua un libro
potrebbe essere il libro del principe
mezzosangue
vediamo
o che carina non mi ricordo come si
chiama questa scrivetelo nei commenti
ha un nome super particolare non mi
ricordo come si chiama questa creatura
comunque supercar in ok scopriamo
finalmente chi è il personaggio era
jimmy guardate che carina le manca ginny
weasley vediamo mettiamole la bacchetta
che carino vediamo gli altri personaggi
che si sarebbero potuti capitare allora
abbiamo harry ron hermione ginny luna
draco ciò snape che non so perché c'è
scritto un rock qua e cedric e qua c'è
harry sulla scopa che penso che sia un 1
raro da trovare o che ho scoperto che
questo serviva per capire in quale casa
è il personaggio in pratica premendo con
il dito si scalda
non so se si vede ma quasi un po di
rosso quindi grifondoro guidi queste
capsule di harry potter ne ho comprato
un altro quindi seguitemi su inizia
graham esso tik tok perché penso che
l'unboxing lo farò o su instagram host
tic toc che voto date a questi regali
scrivetelo nei commenti man boxing
apriamo subito e vediamo che cos'è uno
delle case che carine sono le casse di 6
l'arbor me infatti c'è il gatto di
sailor moon e la luna e poi che belli
gli orecchini di sailor moon
guardate io sono una grandissima fan di
sailor moon e quindi adoro queste
ricchini che belli che voto date a
questo regalo scrivetelo nei commenti
ma che sta facendo
può essere che stia facendo le tasche un
impostore
guardate ha lasciato la sacca per terra
la sacca di regali proporre un guardiano
spero che funzioni
[Musica]
non ci credo suscita rubargli la sacca
dei regali si è accorto un regalo molto
grande e pesante poi questo me lo ero
comprata io da solo
voleva rubarle portarti via di un
motorino boxing di questi regali boxing
ultimi due regali purtroppo vediamo cosa
se in questo grande una candela
profumata
il profumo è di biscotti profumo di
biscotti fiocchi di neve sentiamo rufo
dolcissimo me ne voglia di mangiarlo
bannour non ti mangia che bello il
colore anche tutta rosa ultimissimo
unboxing purtroppo questo l'ho comprato
perché è super famoso in america vedevo
sempre i video è una sorta di lol
surprise ma con delle miniature del
supermercato vediamo come ok aperta
dovrebbe aprirsi d'acqua adesso e ci
sono interi scompartimenti tipo un
mandarino a schizzo iniziamo con il
primo spicchio vediamo cosa troviamo
poche carine
sono è un barattolo di mento se
miniature carina prossimo abbiamo ok
questi non ci sono da noi in italia
perché appunto sono americane quindi
mettono i brand americani quindi mettono
le cose che vendono in america questi
schiavano da adams e sono tipo di
ecco quindi c'è una scatolina di questi
lecca lecca se anche il codice a barre
dietro che carino prossimo spicchio
abbiamo anche questo è americano speravo
che mi capitassero più cose che abbiamo
anche qua in italia comunque sony world
supersound spray candy quindi una sorta
di caramelle in spray e l'ultimo
spicchio peccato mi stavo divertendo
abbiamo una bustina con anche questo
americano purtroppo però super carino il
testo queste sono lo stesso delle
caramelle o gomme da masticare sensi
porco baleno e si chiamano air extreme
fendi si caramelle la bustina sembra
vera chicca vediamo l'ultimo spicchio
poi guardiamo il foglietto nell'ultimo
spicchio abbiamo questo lo spam dello
stesso una cosa famosa in america non so
bene che cosa sia e queste erano quindi
le miniature che abbiamo trovato
cerchiamo il foglietto allora i rari
sono questi gol poi ci sono quelli che
si illuminano al buio
noi abbiamo solo questo dentifricio poi
ci sono alcuni metallic e ci sono alcune
cose che abbiamo anche noi qua
poi ci sono quelli comuni c'è il
dentifricio che abbiamo anche noi anche
quasi qualcosa che abbiamo anche noi in
italia
anche qua sì ne sono tantissimi portati
conti miniature anche la pizza la
scatola di pizza false caramelle e gomme
da masticare
che voto date a queste sorprese
stai forse cercando questa è pazzo e
regali non li ha rubati sei stato tu a
rubarmi e li esatto impostore infatti ho
completato tutte le tasche vinto la
challenge mi dispiace per te ma questa
volta il proprio perso e va bene ma
ricorda gino la sfida ritornerò perché
abbiamo vinto la challenge trovare
regali ne scorsi dall impostore la7 un
bel mi piace se volete altri challenge
con l'impostore iscrivetevi nei commenti
quale regalo è piaciuto più di tutti e
ora vi lascio a 4 caselline su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione
ciao